[Music]
this week on brian ross investigates
the president the playmate and the
crucifix
when donald trump bought this beverly
hills mansion he insisted the seller
include
religious artifacts from a shrine that
belonged to the seller's late mother
that it meant everything to him that he
needed this shrine
but the religious items ended up in the
hands of playboy playmate karen
mcdougall
as a gift from the donald she says
donald had
given me those items personally he
thought they were amazing gifts
and he thought about me trump has denied
he had an affair with the playmate but
do the gifts tell yet another story
of untruths and betrayal it absolutely
shocked me
and horrified me i feel betrayed plus
the spymasters the new book on the cia
and the men and one woman who have run
america's fabled spy agency
and this week's winners and losers in
the media
tucker carlson makes the list once again
see if you agree with the choice
by the editors of meteorite the mayor's
office
claims emails suggesting a cover-up were
taken out of context from the law and
crime
trial network this is brian ross
investigators
good evening and thank you for joining
us and welcome to our viewers on
facebook live
i'm brian ross joined tonight by my
colleague at law and crime
rhonda schwartz and ronda we begin with
the story of the president
the playmate and the crucifix new
details about a gift that apparently mr
trump gave
to karen mcdougal the former playmate
during what she says was a long
10-month affair mr trump has denied the
affair
but she has called come forward with new
details to talk about what was going on
as you recall four years ago she was
paid a hundred fifty thousand 000
not to talk about the affair
that's right brian karen mcdougall was
caught up in the national
enquirer's now infamous catch and kill
operation
but she sued to regain her voice and
tonight she agreed to answer questions
about new information we've learned
about some gifts donald trump gave her
that's right we reached out to her to
confirm the story we heard about these
highly unusual gifts
it's in beverly hills in a high profile
area
it's right across the street from the
beverly hills hotel
my family and i have lived there for
decades
my mother passed away in 2006
and so i was selling the house
for the to for the estate one day
my phone rang it was donald trump
and i was shocked and shock
well okay the bottom line is he was very
personable
uh and very fast we concluded the
transaction
in a matter of under five minutes we met
right in the middle and bang bang done
the next day we met him uh at the house
in beverly hills
and uh we met there
and showed him around and he loved the
home
richard cavalli's mother mary who died
at the age of 93
was a devout catholic and had a small
shrine in her bedroom
with religious artifacts surrounding
photos of friends who had died
before he left he saw
the shrine my mother's shrine in her
bedroom
and he was really he he was he told me
it
was really important to him
that it meant everything to him that he
needed this shrine
and i was really you know i thought wow
this this man is really
he's quite a guy he's really religious
too a successful businessman very
religious and there were certain things
that were dear to me that i didn't want
to part with because they were
things that i lived with every day
so we came to terms on a few pieces
which he took
and he said i need to take these pieces
today i need them on my plane when i go
back to new york and i need them
right now and he said otherwise
it's a deal breaker so he said okay
so he had his people pick up those
pieces
and i thought wow and i'm telling people
that
it's amazing i had no idea he was so
religious
but trump had other ideas for the
woman's religious pieces
they somehow ended up in the hands of
karen mcdougal
the former playboy playmate of the year
model
who says trump gave them to her as they
were in the middle
of what she has called a passionate
10-month affair
we reached karen mcdougall by phone this
week along with her lawyer
carol heller karen how do those items in
that house in beverly hills
from the religious shrine end up in your
hands
brian back in 2006 2007
during the relationship donald had given
me those items personally
because he said he was buying a house
and he wouldn't buy the house
unless he got those religious items and
he gave them to me
they were something that he was
considering a
gift for me because he knew my love of
jesus and so you were in the middle then
of our relationship and he gave them to
you as a present
yes he did and what did he say about
them
he said when i saw the shrine at this
house that he was buying he immediately
thought about me
and he said he wasn't going to buy the
house unless he um
had those items thrown in the deal he
was willing to walk away from the house
and he thought it was great because he
knew my love of god and he also
at the time expressed his love of god
and he gave them to me and wanted to
have them he thought they were amazing
gifts
and he thought about me and why was he
buying the house do you know
he was buying the house because it was
right across the street from the beverly
hills
and he had actually asked me to move in
into the house when it was done getting
remodeled
and what did you say to that
you know i didn't really think about it
too much i just kind of said oh that was
sweet that was nice something along
those lines
i didn't take it serious for myself
because i didn't
think that way and i had my own place in
beverly hills so i didn't need to move
into somebody else's house it was very
nice at the time i guess but no i wasn't
going to even consider moving into
his house no and carol heller
as a lawyer for karen mcdougall what do
you think is the import of this fact
that
donald trump gave these items to to
karen
it definitely proves he was thinking of
her and
it was an incentive to get her to move
into a house
mcdougall sent us these photos of some
of the religious items she says
trump gave her and that she still has so
we've sent you some pictures
that we have one shows this metal
crucifix do you recognize the pictures
yes i do yes i do
in fact the crucifix was given to my
mother
long long ago uh by my brother my
brother gave it to her
and she held a great year so that's
definitely from your house that was your
mother's
definitely 100 percent definitely
and you gave that to donald trump yes i
did
cavali did not know where his mother's
pieces had ended up
until we told him he apparently then
gave them
to karen mcdougall the former playmate
of the year
with whom he was according to her having
a lengthy 10-month affair
well i had heard he had given him to
someone else i didn't hear karen's name
specifically until now
uh but it it absolutely shocked me
and horrified me i feel betrayed they
meant a lot to me
they meant a great deal to me because i
grew up seeing these pieces every day of
my life
on my mother's shrine and
and i just lost my mother in 2006 one
year before so they were especially
important
and i wouldn't have given those even
those few little pieces away to
mr trump uh had i known that they were
going to go elsewhere
would you like these back
yes if that's possible
i don't know what value they have to the
young lady
but i would well we'll ask her for sure
you know i i the message i can leave to
mr cavalli is
um i took care of the items they went
through a good home
i can tell they were loved and cherished
i did appreciate them
they were sweet they were like something
i'd see in my grandma's house
you know what i thought was
a beautiful gift in my eyes as i'm
learning was
actually a betrayal in somebody else's
eyes and for that i feel bad
so if the man would like to have his
mother's items back
they were sentimental i understand i
have my own mother and i would
do anything to have some of her personal
items expensive or not
i'm willing to give them back to him if
he'd like them back
trump sold the beverly hills house last
year and ronda schwartz
what have we heard from the trump
organization about the story about the
religious items well we've been told
there's no truth to this and that there
were no religious artifacts in the house
or involved in the sale of the house
but robert cavalli and his family would
strongly dispute that
without a doubt and so would karen
mcdougall well thank you very much
and next week we'll have more of our
conversation with karen mcdougall about
her relationship with donald trump
coming up next the cia spymasters
inside the cia with a great new book
we're joined by the author chris whipple
when we come back
you're watching the law and crime trial
network
and now to the cia cia offices are
trained to lie
and to keep secrets all in the national
interest
well a new book the spymasters attempts
to get at
at the heart of the truth of the cia and
unearth some of those secrets
it's written by chris whipple cia
directors shape history and the future
and chris thank you so much for joining
us let me start at the very end where
you talk about gina haspel the current
cia director with a quote from someone
saying she'd be a very good
prison camp commandant what did you mean
by that well
you know gina haspel is an absolutely
fascinating character to me
character to me a mystery woman who
flies under the radar
she came out of kentucky a johnny cash
fan and she
cut her teeth as a covert operative in
the back alleys of africa
she then uh formed a a relationship
uh her mentor was the unlikeliest guy
you could imagine
jose rodriguez who was the uh
the architect of the whole enhanced
interrogation program
uh infamously at cia but he became a
kind of feminist mentor to her
encouraged her to go for the
london station as uh at cia and the rest
is history she became
cia director and her record
in my view is really mixed there were
high hopes that she could be
the rare person who could tell donald
trump what he didn't want to hear
but i think she's i think she's really
failed
as the honest broker of information
uh both to congress and to the american
people
and i can give you many examples of that
but it's very difficult
as we all know for anyone to tell donald
trump hard truths
a recurring theme throughout this book
chris is the importance of the cia
director's relationship with the
president
that's really important how do they all
manage it and how has she managed it do
you think
you know it's uh first of all it's
almost impossible to overstate the
importance of the position of cia
director the cia director is the person
we depend on to prevent another 911
or lethal pandemic and it's almost as
you say brian an
impossible balancing act because you
have to tell the president hard truths
and at the same time you have to have
his ear
the cia director commands an army of
analysts
and covert operatives and paramilitary
warriors
and lethal drones but if you don't have
a seat at the table with the president
the whole enterprise is for naught
and this has been true richard helms for
example
famously tried to persuade lbj
that the bombing of north vietnam was
ineffective
lbj would have none of it now fast
forward to gina haspel who has her own
difficulties
telling donald trump what he doesn't
want to hear
a question for you chris from rhonda
schwartz rhonda
is it chris with the cia's obsession
with fidel castro
they've tried to assassinate him they've
tried to invade cuba
what what's up there good question
it had a lot to do with bobby kennedy uh
one of the
great things about the book was the time
i got to spend with
cynthia helms the widow of the
quintessential cia director richard
helms
and cynthia told me and these are the
moments in the book that i love that
where i
really try to humanize the directors
helms would come home at night and tell
her that he had lash marks
on his back not literally but
figuratively because bobby kennedy had
hectored him
all day long about getting rid of fidel
castro
by fair means or foul the kennedys were
obsessed
with that and the other thing that she
told me that i found just
kind of poignant well as you know chris
she said
they were all asked to do things they
shouldn't have done
and god knows helms was a flawed
character
he did cross the line and he committed
illegal acts for lbj
mh chaos mk ultra all kinds of things
and of course at the end of the day when
the crunch came he stood up to richard
nixon and refused to participate
in the watergate cover-up
and chris you make a good point i think
throughout the book that whatever the ca
has done and their failures all along
their career their history of the cia
it's usually done at the behest of the
president right
that's right and one former director
told me brian that there will always be
a cia you could never abolish it because
presidents would then have no one to
blame there's a famous lament
at langley and it is in this town there
are only
policy successes and intelligence
failures
and of course the cia was blamed for
uh 9 11 but i have chapter and verse in
my chapter
on the walk up to 9 11 in which george
tennant and his lieutenants
went over to the white house pounded the
table and told condi rice we had to go
on a war footing now
this was in july of 2001 and yet they
were blamed which is not to say that the
cia hasn't had plenty of screw-ups
and debacles uh over the years but
usually
it's because the president asked them to
do something
all right well chris sipple thank you
very much this is a great book i really
enjoyed it it's a terrific read once
again terrific work for a former
colleague
chris whipple thank you so much brian
great to see you
coming up the winners and losers this
week in the media as
chosen by the editors at mediaite tucker
carlson once again
on the list when we come back you're
watching the law and crime trial network
continuing now with this week's winners
and losers in the media as chosen by the
editors at mediaite and we're joined by
aida mclaughlin who's the
editor-in-chief of mediaite
which like the law and crime trial
network is owned by the dan
abrams media empire aidan thank you so
much for joining us again today
and tonight's first loser is tucker
carlson
once again on your list
yeah if you're the mayor he's
pulled that story off its website the
station is no longer reporting that the
mayor's office covered up the
coronavirus numbers it's now
been reported that some of those numbers
were actually put out in august so the
public didn't seem to know about them
the mayor's office claims emails
suggesting a cover-up were taken out of
context
so we don't know the truth about that
because we don't have all the emails but
we wanted to keep you up to date on what
was happening there and of course we'll
bring you more
so aidan there's a story he's reporting
based on a local station which
completely retracted the story
and yet tucker carlson doesn't seem to
want to buy that
right so let me just give you a little
context on this last thursday tucker
carlson covered this local nashville
story
which had alleged that the national
mayor's office was covering up good news
about the coronavirus
about its spread in bars and restaurants
and tucker crossing covered this at the
beginning of his show and covered it
pretty
extensively and cited the story as
conclusive proof
that leaders particularly democratic
ones were lying to people
about good news about the coronavirus
because for they somehow wanted to keep
power over their population
now i watched this this tucker crossing
segment on thursday night and it didn't
make a lot of sense because
obviously mayors don't want bars and
restaurants in their cities to be closed
for no reason
uh you know they want their cities to
have functioning economies
but anyway the the story that tucker
carlson was basing
uh his commentary on ended up getting
debunked and retracted by
fox 19 the outlet that first reported it
and
it got you know fox and friends which
also covered the story on monday
apologized for covering it uh tucker
carlson comes on his show and instead of
apologizing or correcting
says you know it presents it as an
update says that it was
retracted because of pressure from the
mayor's office which doesn't really make
any sense because
the mayor's office is putting pressure
on the outlet to begin with uh so it's
unclear
why now they would be retracting the
story uh and basically said there's
still questions about whether or not
there's a cover-up
he's now alleging a cover-up about the
cover-up so it was a sort of
pretty embarrassing display from tucker
carlson and i i think genuinely
misleading his viewers about
what this report said and about what it
was what the
outlet was retracting
absolutely and as we all know aidan uh
journalism 101 the most important rule
is if you make a mistake and everyone
does
retract it immediately set the record
straight he doesn't seem to want to do
that
if it cuts across his theory of what's
going on
exactly it's kind of a really disturbing
place
for uh a jurassic enterprise to bri to
be
you know you can have your concerns
about fox news but it's a news outlet
and typically they're good at correcting
things that they get wrong
it's really not a good sign that
when a story has been debunked and
retracted completely
the tucker carlson is misleading his
viewers about that and refusing to
correct it himself
let's go to the winner ali veshi of
msnbc who was hit by a rubber bullet
covering up police protest
and yet the president of the united
states thought that was a wonderful
thing
listen to this all right guys i got hit
yeah i got hit hold on
i remember this guy welchie he got hit
on the knee with a
canister of tear gas and he went down
he didn't he was down my knee
my knee nobody cared these guys didn't
care they moved them aside
and they just walked right it was like
it was the most beautiful thing
a wonderful thing apparently from the
president's point of view
yeah i mean i think we can all agree
that that saying a
anyone getting hit by a rubber bullet uh
calling it a wonderful thing is really
bad
uh particularly for the president to be
doing about a member of the press
uh ali velshi he president trump
mispronounced his name there
but his name is ali velshi he's a host
at msnbc and for the past
year he's really been out in the field a
lot covering the protests
against police brutality uh covering the
coronavirus and
uh a series of other things across
america and
while he was covering these protests
against police brutality he got shot by
a rubber bullet
um it was a pretty staggering moment and
a sign of what reporters have to go
through in the field and it's
embarrassing that
the president is celebrating it
and alive one of the hardest working
people certainly at msnbc or on tv
at all aid mclaughlin thank you so much
for being here
thanks to all of you for watching and
thanks again to the team at long crime
for getting us
on the air and getting us off the air
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you